le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'on ne s'attendait pas à ce qu
alexander benalla fasse parler de lui
pour un livre une sortie surprise de la
part de l'ancien garde du corps et
collaborateurs des manuels macron qui
s'était fait connaître pour ses
dérapages et violence lorsqu'il s'était
fait passer pour un policier lors d'une
manifestation
s'en était suivi un feuilleton politico
médiatique sans précédent dans cet
ouvrage de 280 pages intitulé ceux qui
ne veulent pas que je dise
l'homme de tous les scandales révèle les
coulisses du pouvoir alexandre bédat a
décidé de sortir de son silence et de
dire pour une fois tout ce qu'il sait au
fil des pages il dévoile par exemple les
coulisses des obsèques de johnny
hallyday revient sur la polémique du bus
des bleus sur les champs-elysées et
raconte sa rencontre ainsi que sa
relation privilégiée avec emmanuel
macron alors selon vous je nie les bleus
macro alexandre benalla devait-il tout
révéler alors on a énormément d'infos
vous donner sur cette histoire qui vous
passionne et qui nous a passionné aussi
sur ce livre ce qui est vrai ce qui est
faux voilà vous avez longuement enquêté
fabien le chaos et bernard montiel vous
êtes du côté du non d'ailleurs
alors on va commencer par les premières
révélations puisqu'on l'a découpé en
trois parties sur les révélations déjà
sur johnny hallyday et c'est ce qui vous
intéresse aussi bien sûr sûr il a parlé
des coulisses voilà bien sûr de
l'organisation de l'hommage populaire
alors il ya presque deux ans dione
l'idée nous quitter c'était dans la nuit
du 5 au 6 décembre 2017
et si on en reparle aujourd'hui c'est
bien sûr parce qu'alexandre benalla a
fait des révélations incroyables sur les
coulisses de la mort du chanteur et
l'organisation de l'hommage populaire
on vous a récapitulé toutes les infos
qu'il a donnée sur johnny et après bien
sûr vous nous direz ce qui est vrai ce
qui est faux puisque vous étiez au coeur
du dispositif fabien et bernard garde
c'est dans la nuit du 5 au 6 décembre
2010 est que johnny hallyday
disparaissait dans sa villa de
marnes-la-coquette des suites d'un
cancer
une disparition à l'âge de 74 ans qui
laissera des millions de fans en deuil
face à la pression populaire et à
l'ampleur que provoque le décès du
chanteur le gouvernement décide
d'organiser un hommage populaire le 9
décembre 2017
résultat un million de personnes se
pressent sur les champs-elysées et à
l'église de la madeleine pour saluer une
dernière fois leur idole si jusque là on
ne savait pas grand chose des coulisses
de l'organisation de cet hommage
aujourd'hui alexandre benalla a décidé
de révéler quelques anecdotes dans son
livre il est 2h30 du matin lorsque le
téléphone de brigitte ma console elle
est seule dans les appartements privés
à l'autre bout du sans fil laeticia
hallyday en pleurs annonce le décès de
johnny très vite les équipes de l'elysée
se met en branle et constitue une
cellule de crise nous convenons avec le
manager de johnny qu'il s'occupe de la
partie artistique et technique de la
cérémonie nous du reste alexandre
benalla explique ensuite comment le
manager du chanteur a tenté de se faire
rembourser par l'elysée plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros
j'ouvre la chemise cartonnée à
l'intérieur des factures transmises par
le manager de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros dont l'entourage de
johnny demande le remboursement des
factures de fleuristes des notes d'hôtel
ainsi que leurs notes de taxi cerise sur
cette étrange gâteau la facture du
cercueil et agrafé à la liasse des
révélations qui ne devrait pas faire
plaisir à tout le monde alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya des très très grosse révélation
dans le livre avec sandrine à ceux qui
ne veulent pas que je dise alors sur
johnny hallyday franchement là on a les
deux spécialistes un fabien lecoeuvre et
bien marocaines vous étiez au coeur du
dispositif
fabien donc vous avez vu ce qu'a dit
alexandre benalla qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire c'est très habile il ya
une partie de l'information qui est
intéressante qui est vrai c'est quoi et
une autre partie qui est fantasmatique
raquette intéressante ce qui s'est
réellement passé
c'est le coût des obsèques il ya une
partie qui a été payé par laeticia
hallyday c'est à dire sur une hauteur à
peu près de 460 mille euros c'est à dire
ça représente l'église de la madeleine
le cercueil les fleurs tout le service
cérémonial fatou tout ce qui est
organisée autour le podium pour les
photographes pour les quarts mais entre
60000 euros payés par laeticia hallyday
d'accord et puis après il ya une autre
facture d'un million 400 mille qui a été
payé pour l'hommage national par la
république
ah oui donc ça tout ça les chiffres doxa
scellés de l'affairé ce soir millions
quatre cent mille euros voilà un million
quatre cent mille euros payés par la
république il faut savoir que sa cote
0,6
aux deux centimes à chaque français d'un
côté dire qu'on est 67 millions en
france en plein quelle idée gilet jaune
oui c'est bizarre quand même un 0,02
cent alors je veux dire moi j'ai rien
contre j'ai rien contre l'hommage
national ce que veut dire géraldine
maillet si je peux me permettre
voilà 2 2 voilà de revenir sur ses
propos ce qui est en train de dire c'est
que c'est peut-être c'est un million
quatre cent mille
ces camions quinze millions 4 on aurait
pu les mettre pour autant oui c'est ce
que les en train de dire oui en torrent
quand on rend hommage à jean d'ormesson
à des grands hommes de la rive sud où
des gens qui ont des soldats qui ont été
malheureusement tué était obligé de
rendre hommage à lévis d'avancé par m
est ce que c'est une attaque nos pc je
ne sais pas du tout comment ils src nous
comme disait louis xiv voilà bénard mais
c'est qu'ils ont souhaité un hommage
national et que l'acte fans
l'attendaient les français l'attendent
elle est géniale idée on va pas en faire
50 hommage nationaux qu'il le méritait
et c'était normal que l'état y met de sa
peau il y aura pas un johnny tous les
ans alors là la loi politique alors la
polémique on va y revenir dans un an
restant vous allez vous dire pourquoi ce
qui se passe parce que j'aurais juste
qu'on voit quand même
voilà c'était le 9 décembre 2010 est
donc la france rend hommage à john dalli
d un million de personnes font le
déplacement aux champs elysées 700 biker
accompagnent le cortège et le cercueil
de johnny donc on va voir ces images
incroyables et donc vous allez vous dire
chez vous donc ça ça a coûté en tout 1
million et méchant 4 il faut savoir ce
que famille en or millions 4 + 400
milles non un million quatre cent mais
c'est tout moi par l'état payés par
l'état au miel et 400000 les cartes non
les sages on va essayer les 450 la
totalité et bien sûr des eaux merci et
bon je vous donnerai pas
il ya forcément beaucoup d'émotion et
beaucoup à d'applaudissements peu
partout des jodidio qui est scandé par
la foule qui passait derrière les
barrières tentent d'apercevoir ce
cercueil de bois clair c'est assez
incroyable vraiment et ce cortège qui
commence à descendre sur les champs
elysées
et c'est énorme cette marée noire les
davidson qui est en train là de prendre
les champs elysées petit à petit en est
qu à quelques mètres de l'arc de
triomphe et on va suivre
johnny hallyday dans sa descente des
champs elysées ce magnifique ce
magnifique johnny hallyday dans sa
descente mythique mais champs elysées
on va revoir après quand le cercueil est
descendu de l'église de la madeleine
tout ça donc on vous le dit 1,8 cent
mille euros un million quatre payés par
l'état par l'oréal et 400000 euros payés
à temps elle est ici en vous donne de
vraies infos is war voilà sur ce qui a
été dit dans le livre d'alexandre il a
donc la polémique avant de revenir sur
la polémique jusque vers la moitié faire
une petite prise j'ai quelques détails
par exemple les pompes funèbres
il faut savoir que johnny n'avait pas
souscrit aucune convention obsèques
alors donc il fallait tout payé 1
les pompes funèbres exemple cette
limousine cette vanne le fédéral y
sommes et c'est tout ce qui a eu 65
mille euros ttc la grande photo affichée
à la madeleine vous savez ça joue dans
les ch'tis persan de ces matches est
énorme la grande photo affichée sur la
madeleine 30000 euros ttc les fleurs ne
croyait pas on a parlé de deux cent
mille euros j'ai entendu aujourd'hui pas
du tout les fleurs qu'à payer laetitia
parce que tout ça c'est laetitia qu'à
payer ses 29 1700 euros ttc il appuie le
piano qui avait dans la madeleine
la sonorisation et c'est donc ce qui est
clair c'est que laëtitia a bien payé 450
mille euros de sa roche enfin de son
bien oui et que l'état a payé 1400 et
unibroue a mis en quatre pour la
sécurisation le public le dispositif
dispositif et plus de 1500 pilotes fluo
policiers ont été mobilisés
alors donc la polémique on va venir dont
on va revenir dessus c'est bien le cas
quelle est la police et toute la
subtilité de pour lancer une rumeur on
part toujours d'une information exacte
hier les chiffres les obsèques payés par
l'état ou par lætitia et après on
utilise la vérité pour transformer faire
un fantasme plan hélas le fantasme il
arrive alors on va on va expliquer ce
qu'a dit wow avec son bel adam livre
qu'est ce qu'il est alors lui dans le
livre alexandre benalla certifie que
justement il a eu tout le dossier une
chemise cartonnée avec toutes les notes
de frais de laetitia alors leader de
gagner a voulu se faire rembourser
certains frais qui n'étaient pas là dans
la laure l'interprétation elle est la
mauvaise interprétation
laeticia hallyday n'a jamais voulu se
faire rembourser elle a simplement
communiquer à l'elysée ce qu' elle avait
payé
c'est à dire toute l'organisation de la
cérémonie
il était le personnel à la madeleine une
messe à la madeleine rick autant de
monde
une bâche qu'on met sur la façade ce
qu'a expliqué très bien bernard tout ça
ça a un coût alors 154 160000 euros ira
y raconte tout à alexandrie
lisez l'elysée a simplement demandé
envoyez-nous manama hallyday ce que vous
avez réglé nous on paye par contre tout
ce qui est l'hommage national
c'est-à-dire les un million quatre le
dispositif de sécurité depuis le
funérarium qui était au mont valérien
pour aller jusqu à la madeleine et les
images en témoignent les abysses
l'impressionnant moi j'ai commenté la
cérémonie le ser tf1 avec un terreau
coudray et jean pierre pernaut pendant
cinq heures
c'était impressionnant alors alors un
dispositif on n'a jamais eu ça oui oui
on va revenir sur ce qu'elle dit
alexandre da il dit voilà on apprend
qu'il était que le couple macron était
très proche d'égaliser lorsque j'entre
dans le salon du rez de chaussée
la pièce est pleine de monde j'aperçois
brigitte mâcon sur le canapé avec
laeticia complètement effondré c'est à
ce moment là qu alexandre benalla et le
manager de johnny passent un accord pour
organiser l'hommage du chanteur eddie
nous convenons avec le manager de johnny
qu'il s'occupe de la partie artistique
et technique de la cérémonie nous à
l'elysée du reste très vite laetitia et
mais le souhait d'organiser la cérémonie
à l'église de la madeleine
mais elle ne connaît pas le nom d'un
prêtre susceptible d'officiers voilà et
révèle donc que le manager de johnny a
voulu se faire rembourser certains frais
midi parmi les justificatifs de dépenses
se trouvent les factures des fleuristes
des notes d'hôtel pour le logement de
tous les invités ainsi que la note de
taxi les frais de location de la
sonorisation
cerise sur cette étrange gâteau la
facture du cercueil et agrafé à la
liasse voilà est très étonné donc de
tout ça alexandre benalla appel et
raconte sa conversation avec le manager
de johnny regardez on a repris ce qui
est écrit dans le livre regardez bien
monsieur g vos factures sous les yeux et
je crois qu'il ya un malentendu
pas du tout vous étiez engagé à prendre
en charge des obsèques on ne se comprend
pas très bien on vous a effectivement
dit que nous prenions en charge
l'hommage national à la location de
matériel de sonorisation l'achat de
fleurs sans parler du cercueil alors que
bernard coquelle comment il a pu
inventer tout ça c'est s'il n'a pas
inventé je crois que c'est une très
mauvaise interprétation effectivement
ils ont eu les factures à l'elysée ont
pu c'est sylvain fort qu'à l'époque
était très proche de l'alcool de parole
était à la gloire et de la commune
absolument d'accord qui était là la
réunion et c'est donc tout était clair
il n'a pas vous demander un
remboursement sébastien farran voyez
souvent on dit que je critique manager
moi j'essaie toujours d'être juste
l'ajeli vraiment il est très honnête et
l'ambiguïté justement du dossier c'est
que oui
l'elysée a bien eu les factures ont été
remises par le par sébastien farran le
manager
damman de johnny hallyday l'époque la
colle ambiguïté que c'était pas remis
pour la même chose ce n'est pas pour un
remboursement
c'était pour justifier ce que madame
hallyday avait payé et pour tessa pas la
même chose aux clés tu as où l'état
était déjà accusé à ce moment là est il
ailleurs il y avait un député la
fondation et qui demandait on va voir
les comptes parce que les obsèques d'ali
des ont coûté il l'elysée avait besoin
de justifier pour prouver aussi que
madame hallyday avait bien payer tout ce
qui était la partie personnelle et
intime d'accord donc oui les gens
jean-michel je le livre je mets en temps
ce pont ce qu'on veut mon phoenix
handball alexandre bédat là il a plus
aucune raison de montier ici un livre v
riches ils balancent les choses il est
connu pour dire un peu c'est quelle
vérité puisque et nasri place ma tronche
maintenant il envie de vider son sac du
riz des choses et il est suffisamment
intelligent pour faire la différence
entre une de free qui arrive comme ça
j'en vois ce qu'on appelle est une sorte
de pression veut dire rendre ses frais
il est pas qu on nous dit c'est qu'il le
sait benjamin répond j'ai l'impression
que ce que je mène la danse dans ce cas
là il a effectivement vu avec des
factures et vu ce qu'on a entendu de
gauche de droite
à ce moment là et les conflits entre les
uns et les autres mais n'aurait pas
quitté tenter le coup du côté du clan
hallyday ne sais pas qui d'envoyer des
factures et pourquoi tu veux qu'ils
inventent qu'on a envoyé du circuit et
c'est impossible il a aucune raison il
n'y a pas de honnêtement il n'y a pas de
raison d'inventer un truc pareil il
aurait fait ça je vais répéter ce que
j'ai dit non non non non je répétais
devrait même pas ta gueule non non non
ils ont bien donné l'ensemble des
factures payées par madame hallyday pour
justement bien montrer si jamais il ya
une enquête pour bien montrer que madame
hallyday a bien payé tout ce qui était
personnelle le cercueil les fleurs les
podiums la sonorisation les animations
pour ce qui la concerne et famille et
justement pour que l'on n'accuse pas
l'elysée et donc la charge des français
de plus plusieurs jours de suite pour
dire alors qu'elle couvre non mais ça
génial
c'est là c'est la manipulation des
choses c'est fantastique c'est pas la
première
c'est à dire que effectivement lui
benalla iman pas quand il dit j'ai eu
les factures entre même reçu à l'elysée
je les ai données le sac est fantastique
alors c'est quoi l'homme et
l'utilisation il en fait une autre
utilisation mais choisit de faire bien
enfin il ya quand même y'a corbère du
pouvoir d'un oui maman à temps oui bien
sûr ben alors à bavay
les infos il a les infos fiables alors a
été également au coeur d'une autre
polémique celle concernant le bus des
bleus à leur retour de croatie avec la
coupe du monde ça aussi ça vous
intéresse un voilà parce que ça
forcément ils en parlent mais dallas a
été accusée d'avoir demandé au chauffeur
d'accélérer lors de leur passage sur les
champs elysées vous rappeler la veine et
les joueurs a été que l'accusé de ne
cède pas à ses arrêts clés sur les
champs elysées ça ait fait une petite
polémique les fans étaient très déçus
alors on vous a fait un petit récap de
ça et on aura également toutes les
réponses sur cette histoire du bus et de
la coupe du monde puisque vous avez
encore les infos là on a on a du lourd
et là c'est un goût et cache là le 15
juillet 2018 la france est sacrée
championne du monde en battant la
croatie 4 buts à 2 en russie
les supporters sont en liesse et
attendent avec impatience le retour de
leur héros prévue le lendemain pour
l'occasion un grand dispositif est
organisé sur les champs elysées comme
cela avait été le cas lors de la
première victoire en 1998
si à l'époque la fête avait été un franc
succès cette fois ci l'événement a
tourné court pour les 600 mille
supporters venus célébrer la victoire
le bus des bleus défient laine vitesse
folle et personne n'a le temps de
profiter du moment la cause de ce fiasco
selon la presse alexandre benalla c'est
lui qui était chargé d'escorter les
bleus jusqu'à l'elysée une accusation
qu'il réfute une première fois en
septembre dernier en dévoilant une vidéo
inédite censée prouver son innocence
[Applaudissements]
dans son livre alexandre bédat la
revient une nouvelle fois sur cette
polémique et donne sa version des faits
le chauffeur appuie un peu fort sur
l'accélérateur à plusieurs reprises je
lui demande de ralentir
il relâche un peu la pression puis remet
les gaz dès qu'il peut ce gars doux
avoir rendez-vous chez le dentiste et la
peur d'être en retard ce passage éclair
laisse derrière lui des supporters
frustrés on va revenir sur 7 a fait ses
vrais qu'ericsson behdad donc ni avoir
donné lors d'accélérer reporte la faute
sur le chauffeur le chauffeur a pu un
peu fort sur l'accélérateur à plusieurs
reprises je demande de ralentir il
relâche un peu la pression puis remet
les gaz dès qu'il peut ce gars doit
avoir rendez-vous chez le dentiste et la
peur d'être en retard guy et c'est vrai
contre 98 et 2018 ça n'avait rien à voir
ce n'était pas du tout la même ambiance
regardez les deux ambiances et vous
allez nous donner les infos que vous
avez là dessus je sais que ça vous
intéresse ça c'est vrai que ça nous a
tous les six ont signé sur quoi c'est
fini vous avez les explications claires
[Applaudissements]
à
merci on a vu la différence alors quels
impôts vous avez fabien ou bernard à
l'iphone je pense qu'on est plus dans la
même époque vingt ans plus tard il ya
davantage ce qu'est ce qui est des
problèmes de sécurité
mais c'est justement ça on est après
2001 dont il ya des attentats ils
craignent évidemment des peurs des
menaces donc alexandre bédat n'avait
rien à voir avec ce qu'on a pu dire
c'est lui qui a demandé d'accélérer
non je regarde et il est là il avait
raison là est la raison pénale a
effectivement lui il a même demandé
plusieurs fois aux chauffeurs de
ralentir et le chauffeur sais pas
pourquoi ils ralentissaient et puis
repartent et un peu plus vite
en fait alors est-ce que c'était une
mesure de sécurité est ce que c'est la
préfecture de police qu'il a donné des
consignes en tout cas benalla était pas
au courant parce que benalla il faut
quand même le dire et de gros soucis
avec la préfecture de police en général
étaient tous ses potes flic c'est
d'ailleurs le qu'ils ont balancé un pour
essayer lors du 1er mai tout ça où il a
cassé la gueule aux gens donc voilà
alors il y avait des rapports difficiles
s'est étendue c'était le chouchou des
l'elysée un peu contre toute la police
donc dès qu'on pouvait lui mettre les
bâtons dans les roues mais on l'aimé t
on n'est plus dans la même époque
vous pensez qu'il n'aurait pas dû
balancer puisqu'on va revenir sur le
troisième sujet il parle de ses
relations avec emmanuel macron bien
entendu ça aussi ça vous intéressé parce
qu'on a des infos je pense je pense qu
entendez quand on a un rôle aussi
important dans l'ombre de célébrité je
pense qu'on a un devoir de réserve comme
les médecins géraldine n'est pas
d'accord
non moi je pense qu'il est au coeur du
réacteur et je pense qu'il a raison de
parler il a raison nous dire moi je
trouve que c'est intéressant tout ce que
j'apprends sion johnny k exilés qui a
été un exilé fiscal toute sa vie
aujourd'hui on paye pour ces obsèques
dont moi ça me choque donc je suis
contente qu'il ouvre sa grande gueule
puisqu'il a une grande gueule et puisque
il le revendique et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pénale et il est en
campagne à saint denis je pense que
c'est un homme qui veut montrer qu'il
est dangereux et que là tout moment il a
encore plein d'informations et à tout
moment il peut parler et de toute façon
ça a toujours été comme ça on a toujours
entendu la couturière de la reine en
angleterre le chauffeur de chirac
la cuisinière moi je trouve que c'est
important et toi toi par ailleurs tu dis
tout le temps ce qui se passe en
coulisses
donc je vois pas pourquoi ce serait
choquant pour benalla alors alexandre
bédat était très proche du couple
mâcon et s'est rendue même presque
indispensable il s'était rendu
indispensable j'avais nous en parler
bernard montiel dans son livre il
revient sur quelques anecdotes avec le
chef de l'état regarde avant d'être
l'objet de tous les scandales de
l'elysée alexandre reynal a été au
contraire celui qui assurait la sécurité
du président de la république
à cette occasion il raconte dans son
livre quelques anecdotes qui remonte à
l'époque où il assuré au quotidien la
sécurité des manuels macron comme cette
fois où le président a activé par erreur
la larme de secours alors qu'il se
trouvait sous la douche
aussitôt une équipe d'intervention
d'urgence armés et casqués se rend
devant les appartements privés du couple
présidentiel
brigitte macron qui ne comprend pas ce
qui se passe refuse d'abord d'ouvrir la
porte avant finalement de céder après de
longues palabres brigitte laisse le chef
de l'unité passer la tête dans
l'entrebâillement de la porte et
apercevoir de loin le président qu'il
leur assure d'un sonore tout va bien
alexandre benalla raconte aussi la fois
où il a exfiltré emmanuel macron d'une
situation pour le moins délicate alors
en interview dans les locaux du journal
la provence à marseille une centaine de
taxis en colère des sites d'encercler
les locaux du journal faisant
prisonniers le président à l'intérieur
de la rédaction s'organise alors une
exfiltration acrobatique emmanuel macron
passe le premier par l'échelle et grimpe
sur le toit
il s'est mis à pleuvoir ça glisse je
reste attentif il ne faudrait pas qu'ils
tombent maintenant moins de deux minutes
plus tard tout le monde s'entasse dans
les voitures qui file vers le parc des
expositions mission accomplie
ça c'est ça c'est des infos de coups ni
ce qu'on adore
alors on va on va revenir va revenir là
dessus il ya bfm qui s'est intéressé à
la rencontre entre benalla emmanuel
macron ils regardent et disent c'était
comme une sorte de coup de foudre vous
avez tout nous raconter parce que vous
connaissez cette relation bernard et
fabien regarde alexandre benalla se
souvient bien de sa rencontre avec
emmanuel macron fin 2016
décrit son premier entretien avec le
continent comme une révélation
alexandre c'est ça bien je commence
quand direct le regard droit planté dans
mes yeux la poignée ferme et franche
il se passe chez moi un truc immédiat le
contact est totale je sais que je vais
le suivre
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
2017 le jeune homme assure la sécurité
des manuels macron une fois l'élection
passée il devient chargé de mission
voilà alors bernard ça est vrai alors
c'est amusant l'anecdote si vous voulez
je peux revenir là dessus sur celle de
ou quand les flics ont des bacs à
débarquer dans les appartements privés
il ya plein de petits boutons nous
apprennent à faire de la douche ou l
affaire de la douche ça c'est vrai c'est
qu'en fait il venait juste d'aménager
dans ce nouvel appartement qui était
d'ailleurs assez dans un état assez
délabré faut quand même le dire il ya
plein de petits boutons et si vous
appuyez sur un bouton vous avez la
lumière mais manque de pot si vous
trompez de moutons ça fait venir les
flics c'est pour ça que tout le monde a
débarqué sauf qu il était après sous la
douche le président de république et que
la première dame n'a pas voulu l'ouvrir
et qu'ils ont tapé à la porte ça il le
raconte c'est vrai puisqu'il y était lui
aussi c'est vrai donc ça c'est de cette
anecdote crs étaient non mais c'est vrai
alors ensuite l'autre histoire c'était
quoi c'était sur la sélection
l'exfiltration c'est vrai aussi la
provence et il pleuvait d'ailleurs ils
ont pas ce que c'était l'émeute dehors
effectivement parler toi c'est vrai
aussi et quand ils se sont rencontrés
vous savez qu'il a travaillé moi je les
rencontre est forcément durant la
campagne il a travaillé trois mois
gratuitement
quand le président macron qu'il raconte
mais comment ça c'est facile ont eu un
coup de foudre c'est quoi sinon ça s'est
passé que comme on s'est rencontrés
parce que lui et s'est occupé quand même
d'un campagne de françois hollande aussi
un accord mais s'est occupé de martine
aubry aussi même il a protégé marion
cotillard ont d'ailleurs nos montebourg
d'accepter un garde du corps déjà de
personnalité puis très vite il est monté
parce qu'il est fort et c'est un mec
très brillant très sympa et donc ils se
sont rencontrés à la faveur d'une
manifestation
et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu le sait le
ludovic chaker qui était le chef de la
sécurité de la république en marche qui
l'a sollicitée et se rencontrer avec
macro et hop voilà ah oui fabien non je
suis pas pour toutes ces révélations
alors la douche je suis pas pour après
l'exfiltration par les toits pourquoi
pas c'est une aventure toute vérité est
bonne à dire oui mais je vois d'abord un
choix pas l'intérêt et puis c'est qu'il
est maintenant entre benalla aujourd'hui
et sûrement l'elysée où la présidente
conflit ou parapubliques n'a pas demandé
de livres
non mais là tu as demandé pas sûr qu'un
peintre alexandre bédat est oui alors je
vais vous montrer un autre un autre une
autre extrait c'est que leur complicité
était tellement grande que emmanuel
macron a dû démentir mais avec une
pointe d'humour
certaines rumeurs regarder alexandre
benalla n'a jamais détenu 1 300 m² aller
loin alexandre benalla n'a jamais gagné
10 villereau alexandre bédat la rue n'a
jamais été mon amant alors alexandre
ménages qui ne veulent pas que je dise
alors juste bernard montiel petite
question que je vous pose est est-ce que
vous savez si l'elysée a essayé
d'interdire le livre ou pas du tout ce
qui compte d'abord il n'était pas au
courant ses plans qui allaient contacter
que cette édition plon éditions plon
c'est pourquoi on à l'elysée il était
sincèrement pas au courant personnel est
au courant et là c'est à son retour de
chine où effectivement il a demandé en
pdf un peu voir les polliens dans la vie
on peut le lire dans la viola lui le
président l'a dit oui à son retour de
chine lala hier soir il a eu la géniale
on a pensé le président du livre
d'emmanuel alexandre et dallas je ne
sais pas mais ils sont pas fâchés un
accord parce que and really pas il n'est
pas charge n'est pas charles d'ailleurs
il dit des choses très gentille dit un
homme droit et loyal en parlant de
macron parce que j'ai lu le livre j'ai
eu le temps aujourd'hui de le lire un
peu et non non c'est pas à charge
cela dit je trouve non plus capable il
est très très grande révélation des plus
à charge contre les services français
résidant parce que je veux que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est donc les
services clés ou imaginer les services
qui sont là depuis des années les
services de police et de la préfecture
ils sont morts la ville voit arriver un
jeune homme ambitieux fort et en plus
très compétent benalla kiki qui arrivent
et qui veut tout décider chouchou
évidemment de l'elysée du bureau du
président et donc il s'est pris des airs
quand on habite fait de stopper ou gens
bien là j'espère seulement que tu ris
parce que si les services secrets
français sont pas au courant qu'il ya un
ami qui me semble ce sont les résidents
arabes unis suis très inquiet manal tant
qu'humoriste qui serait fabriqué avait
rien n'est prise ils ont perdu le secret
devrait comme en commun peuvent garder
le secret avait comme le livre de
valérie trierweiler ça a été quand même
très secret aussi personnes le savent et
jusqu'à sa sortie à ce qu'il paraît
qu'ils avaient un nom de code
oui alors lui se faisait appeler
thor et puis pour le livre c'était
domino d'alors donc exactement le livre
avec 90 coach des dominos voilà et
sachez qu'il est attiré des tirs à 60
mille exemplaires et ça ils sont déjà
discale mais bien sûr rien
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont reçu 1000
commandes supplémentaires par des
libraires donc où je vous le dis ça à
l'air d'être parti est un gros carton
oui enfin je veux pas croire non plus
que les services de l'elysée n'était pas
au courant des faits allait faire un
livre parce que on se doute bien que
toute cette affaire toute l'ampleur de
la sphère l'année dernière
mais là où ce que derrière c'était
envers allemand il ya toujours un livre
merci les shiro alors je vous dis on va
voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
voilà oui assure sévère % à 24 %
voilà ils suivent et eve angeli
célébrités ils sont contre la vérité à
les juristes